since the first fossils were unearthed
paleontologists have been carefully
reconstructing the dinosaur record we
know the dinos first show up during the
Triassic period with turkey sized
predators like Coelophysis
then came the Jurassic age when dinosaur
evolution went wild and started creating
Giants at the end comes the Cretaceous
when t-rex and Triceratops roamed the
ancient world but in the midst of the
Jurassic there is long been a
frustrating lack of fossils a gap in the
record the evidence we have suggests
that sometime during the middle of the
Jurassic period was when dinosaurs
really reached they're truly gigantic
sizes by the end of the Jurassic period
you have enormous dinosaurs anywhere
between thirty to fifty maybe to eighty
tons in size tens of times larger than
the largest land animals we have today
somewhere in this blank spot lies the
answer to the riddle
how did dinos go from this to this
clues are emerging from prolific
excavations in China's Gobi Desert
paleontologists are amazed by the number
of species they've uncovered including
many previously unknown a new variation
on the familiar stegosaur
a tree grazing sauropod with a 9 meter
neck new pterosaurs and Raptors even a
little mammal-like reptile now we've
collected more than 400 specimens most
of that comprises approximately 40
different species of dinosaur toy a
nutrition by studying these finds we'll
be able to understand the whole picture
of dinosaur evolution they're very
exciting discoveries the scientists
begin to unravel the genealogies of
these new species in ornithopod an early
big dinosaur would evolve into the great
duckbills of the Cretaceous a primitive
ceratopsian who is decidedly an ancient
relative of the great Triceratops we've
got the oldest representatives the
oldest ancestors if you will to use the
term very very loosely of these kinds of
animals that's pretty darn exciting
these new goby dinosaurs really help us
to understand that they must have
started out as very small animals and
evolved into very large sizes
and that's the big picture riddle of the
middle jurassic what's super-sized the
dinosaurs was this really a passive
process or was there something driving
them towards being very very large
theories are varied some have proposed
that a cataclysmic meteor impact were
volcano left few survivors with little
competition and plenty of room to grow
another says that his countenance
drifted apart the climate became more
favorable to plant life the resulting
abundance of food may have super-sized
the dinosaurs insights into this riddle
may arise as the gap in the fossil
record is finally filled in